we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's my favorite thing
and honestly it's not my favorite thing
here's someone who called in with some
kind of a message to me
but the show is just cranked in the
background so you can't hear anything
and I
um
I believe she's commenting about Kanye
but like her her voice is quieter than
the
shower
you've done that okay I I can't do it
what's funny is I hear myself explaining
the big fight the fundraiser so
unfortunately she also called right
during my fundraising pitch which is
crazy so let me just mention it one more
time Friday December 23rd that's this
Friday
we're doing our last membership special
of the year you can get a discounted
membership you'll get the bonus show
you'll get the commercial free audio
feed all of it oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad but here's the kicker in addition
to you getting a discounted membership
everyone who signs up Friday with the
coupon code is going to see their first
membership payment donated by us out to
an organization that gives cash to
people who need it
and it's going to be doubled your
contribution will be doubled so if you
get a six dollar a month membership the
six dollars gets donated and then it is
matched up to 12 up to the first fifteen
thousand dollars all you need to do for
now is get on my mailing list you can
sign up at davidpackman.com
Friday you'll get an email telling you
what to do
it's gonna be great I hope it's really
successful on today's bonus show
speaking of the bonus show Argentina
have won the World Cup for the first
time in 36 years I wore my jersey today
yes this will be the last round for the
Jersey until the next World Cup
everybody relax we will talk about it uh
we will talk about the insanity also of
the World Cup in Qatar uh and we'll talk
about the next World Cup we will also
talk about an Ohio teacher who told the
principal that using the preferred
pronouns of students violates her
religion oh God this is happening now
and lastly guns confiscated at U.S
airports have hit record levels and it's
not only Madison cawthorne getting
caught it's other people as well all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com get
instant access we will see you then